امس كان
عمري احد عشر عاما وانا من مدينه حلب
السوريه كنت اظن بان الحياه مثاليه وجميله
كما تبدو في القصص السحريه لكن اليوم لم
اعد اعرف شيئا ليست لدي ادنى فكره عما
سيحصل في المستقبل افتقد الشعور الحريه
وعدم الاهتمام كنا نضحك طوال الوقت كنا
سعداء جميعا الكبار والصغار في مدرسه وبين
اصدقائي كان الجميع يشرب السعاده نحن
دائما بعودته الى المدرسه لكن بالنسبه لي
ياتي هذا الحلم بعد كابوس الطويل لانني
اعلم بانه من المحتمل عدم الحصول ذلك على
الاطلاق وقع تفعيل من في الصباح امام
منزله وكانت شقيقتي في تدريب لكره السله
في مدرستها وكان يمكن رؤيه سحابه من
الدخان الكثيف وقطع من الجلسه تتطاير في
ارجاء المكان عندما استيقظت كانت امي تشعر
بالرعب لانها لم تعثر على شقيقتي لكنها
اخبرتني بعدها بان الامور على ما يرام
عندما شغلت التلفاز لارى ما يحصل اقامت
والده بتغيير القنوات بسرعه لكنني تمكنت
من رؤيه الجيش
لقد تغيرت كثيرا بسبب الامور التي شهدتها
اذا كنت في السابق تدمر من الامور التافهه
لكنني اعلم الان بان هنالك على من اكبر من
ذلك على من يقتل فيه الناس من حولي كما
تغير مزاجي فانا غاضبه من الجميع طوال
الوقت ولا اشعر بالسعاده التي عرفتها من
قبل شعوري بالغضب ينصب نحو انانيه الجميع
وب قدرتهم على قتل الاشخاص وقدرتهم على
وضع ابائهم واطفالهم في اوضاع صعبه الجميع
يبقى لعدم وجود طعام كاف الطريقه التي
تصارع فيها الجميع للبقاء على قيد الحياه
انا لا اقول بالقاء اللوم على اشخاص
معينين لكنني انا م كل شخص يحمل مسدسا
الان ومهما تعددت الاسباب من وراء حملهم
للاسلحه
شعرت بالحزن في اليوم الذي قررت فيه عائله
الرحيل الى لبنان ولكنني احاول ان اتذكر
دائما بان وضع افضل من وضع الاخرين الذين
ليس لهم ما ولا القصر الطعام وانا ممتنه
لكل ما لدى
تتنقل الوالده ذهابا وايابا من مساعده
اللاجئين توفر لهم الملابس والطعام والان
وسبب في رغبه بالرجوع الان تتمثل في احداث
فرق في حياتهم وانا عاون والده في تقديم
المساعده لا زلت اشعر بالخوف اتجاه موسى
المزيد من الاشخاص وخافوا بان يزول الامر
المتبقي لديه بالعوده للوطن مجددا عندها
لن يتبقى لدى ما يمكن ان تطلع اليه في
المستقبل